TO SE IN HOLLYWO
WEEK.
IT
FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OR MORE.
E HESTRIL
OUT THEIR JOBS
WITH A.I..
IST FEAR REALITY OR NOT?
ANTOO S OUT FRONT.
THIS IS WHERE WTEAUTOMATED SOL.
>> DR. JONES.
WIZARD EXACTLY LIKE
THAT?YOUNDERSTHO
>> NOTOMPLET
IN THE LATEST INDIANA JONES,
VIORD'S FOR A FLASHBACK WHS SEA.
PHOS OR
.LO>>AYSTUDIOS ARE NGBEDITIONALG
TURNING TONIES LIKE MARSS MARS ?
ZOMBIES. ALIEN R
>> IHIE BEST NER COY. LATESIDIE
RELEASED I21 FEALLAINS LIKE THGN
AND DOCTOR OTTO OCTAVIA'S.
ART BEEN
SAY IN YEARS.
HE THE PREVIOUS
AND WANTEDACT MOMENT WHEN THEY
IGINALLYFORMED THAT
CHARACTEOUNG NAMES, WE HELPE
>>S SAYS THA DE-AGING
A.I.ECHNOLOGY KNOCKS
ANOUETS PROCESS.
EFFECTS WAY OUTRIPS THIS THE BIU
SUPPLY.
NUMBER OF
ARTIST IN THE TH W THAHAS ALSO Y
TO ACTORS LIPS
TO MATCHD AUDIO.
TFI TCLICK THAT I SN
>>N RRN
SPEAKING ANY LANGUAGE OT ENGLIS.
IN FACT, I SUGENGLISH SOMETIMES.
>> WITH THAT TO
NGLISH
LANGUAGE]
ER
MYS LOOK FRENCH.
LOGY CAN EVEN PUT
OT WORDS IN YOUR
>> WHAT
LOOK FOROUWILL NOT PURSUE YOMA
ITBED FOE RPOSE
VEPUTHOBE TO TAK
IN A WAYKS NATIVE
PT,T'S
NOT IN THEOF
IT'S TECHNOLIS
ENHANC, NOCREATE THEM.
>> IT'S A
QUESTION OF THCHNOLOGY.
OW YOU U I COULD BE HIT BY A BUS
TO PERFORMANCES CAN GO OON,
S BEEN
TOON IS ONTUDIO IS
CES.TO
CK CLAS
>> TECHNOLOGY CAN'T REPLACE AN
ACTOR FULL OU D TO TOE AND
EXPECT THAT .E
USE
RIGHT NOW.
BE REPLA ARTIFICIALEY
INTELLIGENCE.
THE,Y, YOU WITH
RIEDFICI TTOENTION JAPE,ATALGH
TING STS PROMP CHATGPT
STTHE CREATIVE
FOUR SECONDSM IT.
TH, OBVIOUSLSERIOUS RI.ISTHRS
OULD BRRIED ABOUT HOW THISTRANME
AT L NOW T
RIDERSBUE IS A FEAR.
E REPLACESE AVS ON AHEINTO MOVI.
OM